let's do another ratio problem that's a
bit of a classic so let's say that i
start off with a certain number of fruit
so i have some number of fruit but i'll
get back to that in a second but we know
that the ratio we know that the ratio
with we know that the ratio of
apples i'll do apples in this
reddish color the ratio of apples
to oranges
to oranges those colors are very similar
let's say it is equal to let's say it is
equal to five to eight
so it's equal to five to eight
five to eight or i could also write it
as 5 to 8 just like that that's the
ratio of apples to oranges now the next
thing that i know about this problem is
that when i take away 15 when i take
away 15 apples so take away
take away
15
15 apples
and
the ratio
the ratio
becomes
the ratio becomes one to four
the ratio of apples to oranges becomes
one to four
how many apples
how
let me write it this way how many total
how many
total
not how many apples how many how much
let me say how much total fruit
how many fruit how much
total
fruit do i have
i have
after
taking away
taking
away
the 15 apples
the 15
apples how much total fruit do i have
so let's do a little bit of algebra
let's say that x
let's say that x is a number x is equal
to the number
of fruit
that we start with that we start with
start with
how much fruit are we going to end up
with at the end we're taking away 15
apples we're not doing anything to the
oranges so we know that x minus 30 i'll
do it in a different color
x minus oh x minus 15
we take away 15 apples x minus 15 is
equal to the number
of
fruit
we
end up with
and up
with we know these two things are true
and now we know that we start off with a
ratio of 5 to 8. so we know that the
ratio of apples to oranges is equal to
five to eight that we start off with or
that's just another way of saying that
for every group assuming that we can
divide our our
our group of fruit into even
where i could divide into a set of
groups and every group has the same
number of apples and oranges that means
that for every
for every
group
of what 13
13 fruits
13 fruits
there are 5 apples
there
are
5 apples
5 apples and eight oranges
and
and eight oranges
that's what this tells me for every
group of thirteen fruits there are five
apples and eight oranges and how many
groups of thirteenth fruit are there
well i have x total fruit so if i divide
x divided by 13 if i take x divided by
13 that is equal to
this is the 13 right here this is the
13. i have 13 fruits per group i have x
total fruit so this is the total number
of groups
so this is equal to the number of
groups
now for every group i have five apples
so how many apples am i starting off
with
this is the number of groups for every
group i have five apples so i am
starting off with five times that apples
5 x over 13 apples
5 x over 13 apples now for every one of
these group i also have eight oranges so
how many oranges do i have i have eight
times that right because for every one
of these i have eight oranges so eight
times that is eight x over thirteen
oranges
fair enough that's what i start off with
now when i'm done we said that the ratio
the ratio of apples to oranges
the ratio of apples to oranges becomes
one to four becomes one
to four
or that another way of saying that is
that for every
for every five right if you add these
two numbers together for every five
fruit
there are
there are
one apple
one apple
and four oranges
and four
oranges
fair enough so how many groups of five
fruit do we have
well this is the total number of fruit
we're left with after we took 15 away so
how many groups of five do we have we
take the total number of fruit
x minus 15 divided by how many fruit we
have per group and this is how many
groups of this is equal to the groups
of five fruit
of five fruit
now for each of these groups i'm going
to have one apple and four oranges so
how many apples and oranges do i now
have after i took away 15 of the apples
i took away 15 fruit
so let's think about this a little bit
how many apples am i going to have
i have one apple for every one of these
groups so that's how many so the number
of groups is the number of apples i have
so i'm going to have x minus 15 over 5
apples
and then how many oranges am i going to
have for every one of these groups i'm
going to have 4 oranges so i'm gonna
have four times this many oranges so we
could write that as
four over five times x minus fifteen
oranges
oranges right that's just four times the
number of groups of five fruit
now what doesn't change i'm messing with
the number of apples but i never changed
the number of oranges
so this number which is the number of
oranges we started off with has to equal
this number the number of oranges we
ended up with there's many ways to do
this problem but this is the way that's
popping out at me that might be
straightforward so let's see if we can
solve for x this has to be equal to that
that never changed so i you say 8x over
13 is equal to
is equal to four
fifths
times x minus 15 and maybe the best way
to do this let's multiply both sides of
the equation times five over four
so times five over four
times five
over four
these cancel out that just becomes one
what does this become
this becomes you see you get a four
divided by four you get a two there this
becomes 10 x over 13
10
x over 13 that's the left hand side is
equal to x
minus
15.
now let's subtract x from both sides and
we get
10 x over 13 minus x is equal to
minus 15.
let me scroll down a little bit
and so what is this this is the same
thing as
10
x over 13 minus 13 x over 13 right
that's just x is equal to minus 15. and
then 10 minus 13 this is equal to so
this is minus 3x
over 13 is equal to
is equal to minus 15.
or we could just multiply both sides of
this equation
by
minus 13 over 3 multiply this side by
minus 13 over 3. i pick that number so
that this and that cancel out and that
and that cancel out and the negatives
cancel out so i'm just left with x on
that side and then the right hand side
becomes what the negatives cancel out
i can divide the 15 and the three by
three so that becomes a five and then
this becomes a one and i'm just left
with five times thirteen this was just
times plus thirteen i wrote that there
just to make sure you understood that
the negatives canceled out so 5 times 13
is what 5 times 12 is 60 so x is equal
to 65
but that is not our answer remember what
x was
x was the number of fruit we started
with and we just figured out that this
is equal to
65 but with the question asked the
question i wanted to know is how much
total fruit do i have after taking away
the 15 apples so the question wants to
know how many after taking the 15 apples
if i start with 65 i give away 15 of the
fruit all of them are apples then i'm
left with 65 minus 15 which is equal to
50
apple oh not
50 pieces of fruit
50
pieces
of fruit that's what they're asking for
50 pieces of fruit if you want you can
go on and figure out how many apples you
started with you finished with the
number of oranges or whatever else this
is what they're asking how much total
fruit not the number of apples total
fruit do i have after taking away the 15
apples